yet another Donald Trump arrest now
appears to be almost certain this summer
let me explain that we've been seeing
some of this news for a bit now
it now seems pretty clear Vice news
reports Trump's next criminal charge is
practically on the calendar let me
explain
former this is from the article former
president Donald Trump's second criminal
indictment looks all but certain to go
down this summer you could even mark it
on your calendar between June 11 I'm
sorry July 11 and September 1st why
those dates because Fulton County
district attorney fonnie Willis Fanny
Willis no matter how I pronounce it
someone writes to me saying I'm saying
it wrong Fannie Willis has formally
asked local officials to beef up
security during that window when she
plans to announce charging decisions in
her long-running investigation of
Trump's attempt to reverse his 2020
election defeat in Georgia
she wouldn't need all that extra
security if she weren't planning to go
after Trump himself former prosecutors
and legal experts say Titus Nichols an
Atlanta area defense attorney and former
prosecutor said quote The Fulton DA's
letter makes it almost certain that
Trump is getting indicted there is no
reason to send something in writing no
other reason to the sheriff so let me
tell you what this is all about
um several weeks ago Fannie Willis's
office did send a letter to the sheriff
indicating requesting additional
security uh during this next period uh
that will contain whatever decisions are
made with regard to Trump and Georgia
that period of time is July 11 to
September 1. and as former prosecutors
lawyers others are saying and it's just
casual observers of this are saying why
would she make that request were it not
because there is going to be a decision
made to arrest Donald Trump and that
there was going to be a similar
um circumstance that plays out in
Georgia as what we saw in New York City
I think that that's pretty likely you
know the if we want to make a sort of
differential diagnosis of the facts you
could say well in order to not show her
hand early
she is requesting the extra security
regardless on the idea that there might
be agitated people whether or not Trump
is charged or something along those
lines maybe like maybe she says well if
I charge Trump his supporters will be
furious and they might show up and be
violent and if I announce I'm not
charging Trump people who want him
charged will show up and be violent the
reason that's hard to believe is we've
seen no evidence that there's no reason
to believe or fear that people who think
Trump should be charged are going to
show up and be violent if he isn't
charged we just I just don't there's no
reason to think that that would happen
so I do think the most likely scenario
is Trump is going to be charged in
Georgia this is not going to impact his
existing supporters very much in all
likelihood the question is is it going
to impact Trump's ability to be out and
campaigning if now with another arrest
another indictment another pending trial
if this all starts to get in the way of
trump being able to just go and campaign
it may start to make him an unappealing
candidate the Counterpoint to that is
there absolutely are Mega people on the
right on the Republican uh in the
Republican voting roles who will
actually be energized if Trump is
arrested again they will feel that he is
being scapegoated they will feel that he
is being you know and remember the key
word is feel they will feel that he is
being targeted for political reasons
rather than he did things no former
president has ever ever done the Georgia
case in particular is interesting
because it is arguably where the the
most serious and most relevant charges
may come from and there are other
prominent Republicans that are wrapped
up and Tangled in the Georgia mess
Lindsey Graham and so many others it is
not yet clear even whether or not Trump
is charged and it looks like he will be
that may not be the full list there may
be even more Republicans charged the
fake elector scheme required dozens of
Highly placed people so this could
actually be a major major takedown of a
number of conservative figures speaking
legally of course and as always you all
know I am for Law and Order and I
actually am for Law and Order if there
is no evidence against someone they
should not be charged I don't want
anybody charged for political reasons
reasons of Retribution revenge or
whatever the case may be if there is no
evidence then do not charge people what
I want is for the justice system and for
uh the investigations to happen
unfettered unconstrained by political
meddling or whatever the case may be
look at the evidence compare it to the
laws and then make a charging decision
that should apply to Trump
it should apply to Biden Hunter Biden
Hillary Obama people who work uh locally
people who dog walkers McDonald's
employees this should be the standard
that is always applied and I am
consistently for that so the news is
almost certainly Trump's getting
arrested again if and when it happens we
will have it for you it is the Friday
show in the sense that it's Friday and
this is the show we will take a very
quick break and continue right after
this
I've had such trouble finding a great
razor where I am not cutting myself or
getting those Nicks on my skin which are
so common with the cheap disposable
razors you have to meet our sponsor
Henson shaving Henson actually
manufactures parts for the International
Space Station and the Mars rover and
they are bringing that exact same
Precision Engineering to the Shaving
experience it hurts when you shave
because blades extend too far and thus
they wobble slightly but with their
Aerospace grade CNC machines Henson is
able to make metal razors that extend
just
0.0013 inches that's less than the
thickness of a human hair which means a
secure stable Blade with the vibration
free shave it also has built-in channels
to evacuate the hair and the cream no
more clogs no more rubbing your thumb on
the razor to get the hair out I use
Henson at home shaving is a great
experience now Henson wants to be the
best razor not the best razor business
which means you only need to buy it once
and it's awesome go to hensonshaving.com
Pacman add a razor and a hundred pack of
blades to your cart then enter the code
Pacman to get the hundred blades for
free that is a three year Supply the
link is down below